Olha, eu vou te fazer uma pergunta
direta agora. Você tem uma pessoa na sua
família, provavelmente mulher, que toma
cálcio todo santo dia para proteger os
ossos, certo? E se eu te falar que esse
cálcio pode estar indo pro lugar errado,
direto para as artérias dela ao invés
dos ossos, que pode estar transformando
as artérias em tubos rígidos,
endurecidos, calcificados e que isso
pode estar aumentando o risco dela de
infarto e derrame, você querer saber,
né? Então fica comigo porque nos
próximos minutos você vai entender
porque que esse conselho médico que todo
mundo acha óbvio, tomar cálcio para ter
osso forte, pode estar fazendo
exatamente o oposto do que a gente
imagina. E mais importante, você vai
aprender o que fazer diferente. Antes de
qualquer coisa, vamos deixar uma coisa
bem clara. Eu não estou dizendo aqui que
cálcio é veneno. O cálcio é essencial
pra vida. 99% do cálcio do corpo está
nos ossos e dentes. Isso dá estrutura. O
1% restante regula a contração muscular,
impulsos nervosos, secreção hormonal.
Sem cálcio você não existe. Mas aqui
está o problema. E é um problemão. O
corpo humano é um sistema incrivelmente
complexo de equilíbrio. Não basta enfiar
nutriente goela abaixo achando que vai
resolver. O que importa não é só quanto
cálcio você toma, mas para onde esse
cálcio vai. Deixe contar o que a ciência
mais recente está mostrando. Tem um
estudo chamado mesa, multiethnic
study oferosclerosis,
que acompanhou mais de 5.000 pessoas por
10 anos. Sabe o que que eles
descobriram? Que quem tomava suplemento
de cálcio tinha 22% mais risco de
desenvolver calcificação nas artérias
coronárias. Coronárias são as artérias
que alimentam o coração. Quando elas
calcificam, você está um passo do
infarto. Agora, presta atenção nesse
detalhe crucial. O cálcio da
alimentação, aquele que vem do queijo,
da sardinha, das folhas verdes, não teve
essa associação. Pelo contrário, até
pareceu proteger, mas o cálcio de
comprimido, esse foi direto entuper as
artérias. E tem mais, um estudo
publicado no Journal of the American
Heart Association mostrou que mulheres
que consumiam mais de 14400 mg de cálcio
por dia tinham um risco aumentado de
doença cardíaca. Mas, ó, o detalhe,
quando esse cálcio vinha de suplemento,
o risco mais que dobrava, dobrava, não é
um pouquinho mais, não é o dobro. Aí
você me pergunta, mas por que que isso
acontece? Por que que o cálcio do
comprimido faz isso e o da comida não? A
resposta tem a ver com velocidade e
absorção. Quando você toma um comprimido
de 1000 mg de cálcio de uma vez, você
cria um pico gigante de cálcio no
sangue. É tipo jogar um caminhão de
areia num córrego. O corpo não consegue
processar aquilo tudo de uma vez. E o
resultado, esse cálcio em excesso
circulando no sangue, começa a se
depositar onde não deveria, nas
artérias, nas válvulas cardíacas, nos
rins. Já o cálcio da alimentação, ele
entra devagar ao longo do dia, em doses
pequenas que o corpo consegue lidar. É a
diferença entre tomar 1 L de cachaça de
uma vez e beber um copo de vinho durante
o jantar. Mas espera que tenha um plot
twist nessa história. Estudos recentes,
e quando eu falo recentes, eu tô falando
de pesquisas de 2024, 2025, mostram que
o cálcio não é o bandido solitário dessa
história. O problema é que a gente está
tomando o cálcio sozinho, desacompanhado
dos cofatores que ele precisa para ir
pro lugar certo. E aqui entra a vitamina
K2, especialmente na forma de MK7, que é
a estrela que a indústria farmacêutica
não quer que você conheça. Sabe por quê?
Porque o K2 não tem patente, é um
nutriente natural que não dá lucro pra
big farma. A vitamina K2 ativa uma
proteína chamada MGP, matriz GLA
protein, que é o mais potente inibidor
da calcificação vascular que existe.
Quando a K2 ativa essa proteína, ela
literalmente pega o cálcio que está
circulando no sangue e impede que ele se
deposite nas artérias. Ó, você não vai
paraa artéria, não, você vai pro osso.
Tem um estudo de Damarqui chamado Avadec
Trial, que suplementou homens com 720
microg MK7 mais vitamina D por 2 anos. E
o resultado, o grupo que tomou K2 teve
progressão significativamente menor de
calcificação nas artérias coronárias. E
nos pacientes que já tinham calsificação
mais avançada, o efeito foi ainda mais
impressionante. Mas tem mais coisa nessa
equação. Tem o magnésio, que é outro
nutriente que todo mundo é deficiente,
ninguém fala. Estudos mostram que baixos
níveis de magnésio estão associados com
mais calsificação arterial. O magnésio
faz duas coisas importantes. Primeiro,
ele se liga ao fosfato no sangue e
impede a formação de cristais de
hidroxapatita, que é o tipo de cristal
de cálcio que se deposita nas artérias.
Segundo, ele regula a função das células
musculares lisas das artérias, impedindo
que elas se transformem em células
formadoras de osso. Sim, isso acontece.
As células das suas artérias podem
começar a agir como se fossem células
ósseas. Um estudo do Fremingham Heart
Study mostrou que quem consumia mais
magnésio tinha 34% menos calcificação
nas até coronárias. 34%.
E aqui está o problema. A maioria das
pessoas não consome nem o mínimo
necessário de magnésio. O brasileiro
médio está com deficiência crônica de
magnésio por causa da dieta
industrializada, cheia de farinha branca
e açúcar e pobre em verduras, grãos
integrais e oleaginosas. Agora vamos
juntar os pontos. Você tem uma senhora
de 70 anos que vai no médico com
osteopenia. O que que o médico faz?
Paracreve cálcio e vitamina D. Só isso.
Mas a vitamina D aumenta a absorção de
cálcio no intestino. Então você tem mais
cálcio entrando no sangue, sem K2 para
direcionar esse cálcio pros ossos, sem
magnésio para impedir a calcificação das
artérias. E qual que é o resultado? Você
já imaginou, né? O cálcio vai paraa
artéria ao invés do osso. A osteoporose
continua progredindo e de quebra a
pessoa vai ganhar calcificação vascular.
É o pior dos dois mundos. E tem um dado
assustador. Estudos em modelos animais
mostraram que quando você dá doses altas
de vitamina K, eu estou falando de doses
terapêuticas e não nutricionais, você
consegue não só parar a progressão da
calcificação, mas reverter calcificação
já existente. Em seis semanas houve
redução de 37%
da calcificação arterial, em 12 semanas,
53%.
Isso significa que calcificação não é
necessariamente permanente. Ela pode ser
revertida se você fornecer os cofatores
certos. Então o que que a medicina
convencional deveria estar fazendo
quando prescrever suplementação de
cálcio? Sempre associar prescrever junto
K2 MK7 e magnésio. Mas isso não acontece
na maioria das vezes. Por quê? Primeiro
porque os estudos clínicos grandes que a
indústria farmacêutica financia focam em
drogas patenteáveis. Vitamina K2 não tem
patente, magnésio não tem patente.
Segundo por os guidelines médicos são
lentos para mudar. Eles se baseiam em
estudos antigos que não consideravam
esses cofatores. Terceiro, porque tem
muito médico que simplesmente não estuda
nutrição. Pra maioria dos colegas,
nutrição é dar estatina se o colesterol
tá alto e pronto. Mas na abordagem
funcional, a gente olha os mecanismos. A
gente entende que o corpo não funciona
em partes isoladas, que dar cálcio sem
K2 é tipo querer construir uma casa sem
engenheiro. Você tem o tijolo, mas
ninguém para dizer onde colocar. E aí o
cálcio vai parar onde não deveria. Outra
coisa importante, se você já toma
cálcio, não precisa entrar em pânico e
parar tudo de uma vez, mas você precisa
adicionar os cofatores. A dose de K2 que
os estudos mais recentes usam varia de
90 a 180 microg por dia. Paraa magnésio,
a maioria das pessoas se beneficia de
300 a 400 mg de magnésio elementar por
dia, de preferência nas formas
queeladas, como glicinato, malato,
trionato que tem melhor absorção. E aqui
vai o pulo do gato. Tome o magnésio
separado do cálcio, porque eles competem
pela absorção. Cálcio de manhã, magnésio
à noite, por exemplo. E tem um detalhe
que pouquíssima a gente sabe. Se você
toma anticoagulante, tipo vafarina, você
não pode tomar K2 sem falar com o seu
médico, porque a K2 interfere com a ação
da vafarina. Mas se você não toma
anticoagulante, K2 é extremamente
segura. Não existe toxicidade conhecida
mesmo em doses altas. Já foram testadas
doses de até 45 mg, isso é 45.000 1000
microgas de MK4, outra forma de K2 e sem
efeitos adversos. Agora vamos falar de
comida porque nem tudo precisa vir de
comprimido. As melhores fontes
alimentares de K2 MK7 são alimentos
fermentados. O NATO, que é a soja
fermentada japonesa, é campeão absoluto.
Uma porção pequena de Natô tem mais de
1000 mg de K2. Só que brasileiro não
come,
tem cheiro de chulé, é o que dizem.
Outras fontes são queijos fermentados,
tipo gudá, briê, certos queijos duros,
gema de ovo de galinha caipira também
tem, embora em quantidade menor. E para
magnésio, folhas verdes escuras são
excelentes. Couve, espinafrea, celga,
oliaas, especialmente amêndoas e
castanhas, cacau puro, abacate, peixe,
grãos integrais.
Mas aqui está a realidade. É muito
difícil atingir doses terapêuticas só
com alimentação príncipa de K2. A não
ser que você coma anatô todo dia, você
vai precisar suplementar. E não tem nada
de errado nisso. Suplemento bem feito
nas doses certas, com os cofadores
certos é ferramenta terapêutica
legítima. Deixa eu resumir para você o
que realmente importa aqui. Primeiro,
cálcio isolado em doses altas,
especialmente na forma de suplemento,
aumenta risco de calcificação arterial e
eventos cardiovasculares. Isso está
documentado em múltiplos estudos.
Segundo, o cálcio da alimentação não tem
esse problema porque ele entra devagar e
vem acompanhado de outros nutrientes.
Terceiro, K2, MK7 e magnésio são
absolutamente essenciais para direcionar
o cálcio pro lugar certo. Sem eles, você
está jogando roleta russa com suas
artérias. E quarto, a medicina
convencional não prescreve esses
cofatores porque não fazem parte das
guidelines antigos e porque não gera o
lucro pra indústria farmacêutica.
Quinto, isso é corrigível. Você não
precisa ficar refém de sistema. Se você
tem alguém na família tomando cálcio,
provavelmente tem, mostra esse vídeo
para essa pessoa. Não precisa parar o
cálcio de uma vez, mas precisa adicionar
o K2 e o magnésio e, se possível, trocar
o cálcio de comprimido por fontes
alimentares. Sardinha com osso é uma das
melhores fontes de cálcio biodisponível
que existe e vem com3 de brinde.
Queijos, iogurtes, folhas verdes. O
corpo reconhece esse alimentos. e sabe o
que fazer com eles. E por último, se o
seu médico acha que tudo isso é bobagem,
que K2 e magnésios não fazem diferença,
você tá na hora de procurar um
profissional que esteja atualizado com a
literatura científica dos últimos 5
anos, porque essa informação não é
alternativa, não é modinha, é ciência de
ponta publicado dos melhores jornais
cardiovasculares do mundo. Journal of
the American Heart Association,
Circulation, JCC. A informação está lá.
O que falta é médico lento e aplicando.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos e na
comunidade fechada não existe filtro. Eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica, casos de reversão
que parecem possíveis, combinações of
label que funcionam, além de
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames. É basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários. São lives semanais
respondendo perguntas PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique em seja membro. Não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ir ainda mais fundo,
existe o nível dois. E aqui é onde
separamos quem está brincando de quem
está realmente comprometido. A cada duas
semanas nós fazemos lives de imersão
total com 2 horas de duração, secando
artigos científicos linha por linha,
debatendo controversas que ninguém ousa
tocar, revelando os bastidores das
pesquisas que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna parte
visível dessa comunidade elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você vai estar ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre você aprender, é sobre
pertencer ao círculo interno de quem
está mudando o jogo. Poucos têm essa
coragem. Será que você tem? M.